[Music]  [Music]  get on board children  we're running out of time the world  needs  changing both yours and mine  need to cause good trouble  peaceful like john today we're all equal  oh the struggle will be gone  three tone brothers sisters stay  strong hearts are  changing march on march on  400 years of history couldn't be  more wrong a reckoning's coming  much on my job  i came here in shackles picked the  cotton in  chains that's the sin of my people  and i carry that shame  god knows you must be weary you've been  dreaming so long  you built this country so  march all three young brothers  sisters stay strong  hearts are changing march on  march 400 years  of history couldn't be more wrong  i reckon it's coming much  [Music]  heed the words of martin luther lift  every voice and sing along  a change is still coming march on  march martial